the episode starts with a 9-1-1 distress
call on june 14 2015 from a worried
neighbor lacey stating nobody at dd's
house is answering lacey cries for the
police to hurry revealing that her
neighbor has posted some terrible and
depressing posts on her facebook page in
the meantime her mother mel enters dd's
residence through a window to check if
anything bad has happened as she stares
at the silent house the police sirens
can be heard in the background after a
while the detectives finally enter
dede's house and discover her badly
stabbed corpse in the main bedroom they
share the news with lacey and her mother
who are now worried about dede's
daughter gypsy's whereabouts the show
then flashes back to seven years earlier
dede lives with her second
wheelchair-bound daughter gypsy rose in
their new home provided by habitat for
humanity the two arrived in the new
neighborhood in springfield missouri in
2008 following the destruction of their
previous home caused by hurricane
katrina in 2005. one day they sit for a
television interview where dede talks
about how getting the house was like a
disney dream for her in the next scene
dede shaves gypsy's head in the kitchen
sink as they talk dee prepares a
medication concoction and injects it
into gypsy's stomach via a long tube
my mom would just give me aspirin later
at night dede sings a lullaby for her
daughter and makes her wear a sleep
apnea machine to bed after leaving gypsy
to sleep didi opens a closet full of
medicine bottles and takes a few pills
for herself including one named sleepy
baby the next day they get a surprise
visit from their neighbor lacey she
offers gypsy a makeover and dede
reluctantly allows it during the
makeover the two girls start to bond and
the gypsy shares that her father made
fun of how she walked when she was a
child before she used a wheelchair all
this time didi is closely listening to
the girl's conversation later she makes
sure to scrub off all the makeup much to
gypsy's dismay the following morning the
mother-daughter duo decides to venture
out and meet new people in the
neighborhood first they come across
lacey and her boyfriend who are washing
their car dede heads over to lacey's mom
mel who is chilling out with her friend
shelly the three talk about parenthood
but dede keeps mentioning about how her
daughter is suffering with diseases like
paraplegia epilepsy anemia and the heart
murmur shelly and mel are amazed by
dede's strength to look after her poor
kid as the mothers talk everything comes
to a screeching halt when lacey offers
gypsy a sip of coke didi immediately
rushes over to her daughter and tells
everyone that gypsy is allergic to sugar
anybody else starting to get bubble boy
vibes the following day dede takes gypsy
to the mall gypsy pleads with her mom to
buy a blue necklace but rather than
buying it she slips the chain into
gypsy's bag it isn't until the last
moment that she spots her neighbor mel
looking at her in the evening dede tries
to talk to mel but the latter simply
ignores her hence with the intention of
buying mel's silence dede plans a party
at her house inviting all neighbors
meanwhile gypsy takes the time to search
best friend and boyfriend's kiss on her
mom's laptop and immediately deletes the
search history before her mom gets home
the movie then cuts to the party where a
lot of people are gathered everyone is
having fun out in the yard and dede
talks to all the people one by one just
then gypsy decides to eat a cupcake
which can be fatal for her seeing this
her mother freaks out and immediately
rushes to stab her with an epipen this
stuns everyone and they wonder how much
pain deedee has endured to care for her
sick daughter gypsy wakes up at the
hospital and overhears the doctor
telling dede that she is not allergic to
sugar while leaving they find mel
waiting outside to drop off dede's
wallet that she had left at the party
dede thanks her and laments that she
doesn't want people to see her as a
woman with a bad reputation due to her
past mel also reveals that she has her
own troubled past so she understandably
offers to start afresh at night gypsy
lays her daughter down for bed and puts
on her usual sleep apnea machine as
gypsy fades off to sleep didi opens a
stash of checks addressed to claudine
blanchard possibly her real name after
that she goes to bed next to her
daughter less than an hour later gypsy
wakes up while her mom is asleep and
shuts off her machine to get out of bed
gypsy who had been a wheelchair user up
until this moment stands on her feet and
slowly tiptoes her way out of the room
she then goes to the kitchen to eat
whipped cream while readying her epipen
but after she licks a handful there's no
shock it turns out that she isn't
allergic to sugar her mom had just lied
about it when she returns to her room
she is startled to see her mom awake who
furiously tells her to get back to bed
on another night gypsy sits in front of
her laptop watching makeup videos on
youtube while enjoying a tub of frosting
and a coca-cola drink she soon feels a
pain in her tooth perhaps having a
cavity after all the sugar she's been
eating secretly the following morning
dede wakes her daughter up to share
great news gypsy has been named the
community's child of the year what the
hell is that well she gets excited she
notices gypsy's tooth troubles dede
immediately suspects it is an underlying
condition and takes her daughter to see
their pediatrician dr harley at the
hospital they meet with the doctor and
dede thinks gypsy's acid reflux has
returned which is ruining her teeth
while the doctor calls for a
gastroenterologist dr chandra to look at
gypsy dede sneakily steals his
prescription pad from the counter in the
following scene dr chandra suggests dede
make an urgent dental appointment
however dede wants to treat her
daughter's acid reflux first prompting
the doctor to become suspicious hence
she asks for gypsy's medical records but
didi states that they were lost during
hurricane katrina before the doctor can
say anything deedee rushes her daughter
away later dr chandra asks dr harley if
he has confirmed gypsy's full medical
history but the latter has no answer
after this the scene cuts tadi and gypsy
waiting in their car outside a pharmacy
surprisingly dede takes out the writing
pad that she had stolen and forges some
prescriptions on it don't forget to
write scissor mummy back to the present
the detectives examined dede's stab
wounds meanwhile lacey suspects someone
might have been after gypsy instead of
her mother she also informs the
detectives about all of gypsy's
underlying illnesses the movie goes back
to 2009 where gypsy has one of her teeth
rot out completely while brushing them
she whimpers with excruciating pain as
the sink is left in a bloody mass
because of this her mother starts giving
her more unnecessary medications after a
while dede takes gypsy over to lacy's
who is hanging out with her friends as
the group discusses trivial topics one
of the girls notices gypsy's bad tooth
prompting gypsy to reveal that she has
been sneaking out to eat sweet things at
night meanwhile dr chandra isn't ready
to give up on her suspicions she makes
several calls to hospitals to learn more
about gypsy's medical history she
finally places a call to child
protection services and alison one of
the representatives pulls up on dede's
doorstep seeing this dede immediately
springs into action feeding sleeping
pills to gypsy to make her look sick
alison introduces herself and looks
around the house when she asks for gypsy
dede lies to her saying that her
daughter has the mind of a
seven-year-old soon alison sits for a
talk alone with a medicated gypsy while
dede lurks at the doorway she
interrogates the little girl
continuously to check if she is fine
however as gypsy speaks she appears
disoriented and dizzy hence confirming
her mother's claims after this alison
questions dede about her social security
card not matching the name on her
address but as usual the mother uses
hurricane katrina as an excuse with this
alison decides to conclude her visit as
she didn't find any suspicious activity
alison should be fired that whole trip
was sauce as hell next dede takes gypsy
to the dentist to have her teeth
extracted after she is put under
anesthesia she wakes up to find most of
her teeth gone the little girl weeps
while looking at herself in the mirror
with a swollen mouth later gypsy tells
her mom that she doesn't want to attend
her child of the year award ceremony not
wanting to show herself in such a state
in front of people however this only
angers deedee and she yells that gypsy
is going to the event we are then taken
to the award day where dede is preparing
her daughter for the big event she also
brings some dentures for gypsy to wear
while on stage after a while her name is
called upon on the stage for the child
of the year award along with the
recognition comes financial help of five
thousand dollars dede cannot contain her
happiness after receiving the check
while the crowd cheers them on she then
gives an emotional speech before she and
gypsy sing an impromptu rendition of
i'll be there cringe meanwhile dr
chandra calls to check on gypsy and
manages to get an appointment with her
despite bd's reluctance in the evening
gypsy and dede are back at the hospital
for their appointment with dr chandra in
her room the doctor manages to talk with
gypsy alone and tries to convince her
that she isn't allergic to sugar she
offers a can of coke but gypsy refuses
to drink it out of loyalty to her mom
just then dede arrives prompting the
doctor to put away the can and start
examining gypsy back in 2015 the cops
continued to search didi's home to find
clues to the murder sometime later lazy
tells them of a secret facebook account
gypsy had created to make friends and
assumes she even had a boyfriend
following this the movie again flashes
back to 2011. dede collects all the
money from a gofundme page that pours in
for her supposedly sick daughter
meanwhile gypsy continues her routine of
sneaking out of bed at night to watch
youtube videos on kissing and cosplays
next she prepares for fantasticon a
cosplay event while putting some makeup
on her mom while checking in at the
event dede says her daughter's birth
year is 1995 when the girl at the
counter asks her this confuses gypsy as
she was always under the impression that
she was born in 1993. soon the two run
into shelly and her boyfriend at the
event meanwhile russ one of the
neighbors notices deedee and tries to
ask her out for a date however dede
changes the subject and asks to leave
for the restroom while gypsy approaches
a guy dressed as wolverine he introduces
himself as scott and they chat about
their favorite marvel characters gypsy
then urges scott to see the delorean
from back to the future to which he
agrees luckily they are invited to the
front line scott picks gypsy up to put
her in one of the seats and the two have
fun together sadly the good time doesn't
last long as dede interrupts them and
hurries gypsy home at the same time russ
again shows up trying to get didi's
attention and shares that he too had a
son in a wheelchair before he died after
they reach home and tuck themselves in
bed gypsy sneaks out again to open a
facebook account hoping she will find
scott online however she becomes
confused about her birthdate again so
she checks her mother's purse to her
surprise her actual birthday is in 1991
meaning she's 19 years old angered by
her mom's lies because this makes her a
predator if she goes after scott she
steals some cash from her the following
day at a gas station gypsy secretly buys
a cell phone in the next scene dede
surprisingly gets a call from russ
prompting her to ask where he got her
number meanwhile gypsy starts talking
with scott through her new phone sharing
about her hospital staff whom she refers
to as her friends dede continues to get
phone calls from ross but their brewing
romance cuts short when he offers to
help her with her sick daughter as
expected dede doesn't want anyone close
enough to unravel her lies on the other
hand gypsy has also become close with
scott she subtly suggests that she wants
to run away with him she also gives him
her address if he wants to send a gift
lo and behold he sends her a package
containing a red ariel wig one day lacey
catches gypsy smiling at her phone and
asks her about it unlike her mother the
little girl shares everything she talks
about scott who she refers to as prince
charming before departing she also tells
laci about her secret facebook account
which is under the name emma rose later
at night gypsy gets a message from scott
saying that he's in an emergency room at
the hospital so he cannot talk this
worries gypsy and she immediately heads
to the hospital when scott sees her he
is taken aback that gypsy can stand on
her two feet back at home dede wakes up
to find that her daughter is nowhere to
be seen at the house she then finds a
note gypsy left stating that she is
fleeing with her prince charming and
never coming back elsewhere scott takes
gypsy to his place she is seemingly
happy to be home with her prince
charming and puts some ice packs on his
bruises after chatting for some time
they kiss but get interrupted by dede at
the door dede begs her daughter to
return home and admits that she nearly
had an anxiety attack while she was gone
hearing her mom gypsy reluctantly agrees
to return before leaving dede tells
scott that gypsy is only 14 years old
once back home dede pulls her daughter's
red hair and forces her back into the
wheelchair to see what happens next
watch the second part in series recap